what's up everyone welcome back for
another comic-con 2022 interview i'm
excited about this one because there's a
new animated series we've got the team
behind little demon here and you could
probably tell by the title that this is
right up my alley i am so into i'm into
horror in general but i'm so into just
like hard r comedy right now and you
guys crush it in that department thank
you so much
oh man thanks so i want to start with
the three of you here can you tell us
how the three of you met and then what
you saw in each other that made you say
like these are the right creative
partners for me to work on a wacky idea
like this oh wow that's a great question
um well the three of us met well i met
darcy i think darcy and i met was it's
been now like 20 no 15 16 years or
something like that many multiple years
um yeah and we started sort of
collaborating artistically like we had a
very like mind thought of like
creatively and then and kieran and i
also met was that that was also 15
something years ago but separately the
and then the three of us all worked
together on uh a sketch uh sketch
together um and where he directed and we
both acted and it was and so we just all
started working together we realized
that we all had sort of the same
i don't know has to sell without
sounding like a cliche but like insane
crazy wacky thoughts um but i think we
all had very similar like comedic
sensibilities and like that we love
horror and comedy together and so we
started on live action stuff together um
just i don't know like yeah no i think
when we like yeah we did this sketch
like it was this ring pop parody sketch
that aubrey was actually in cassette and
aubry i've known each other for a long
time and it was just like
the best day on set i've i've ever had
just feeling like you're like at home
with the people you're working with and
the yeah it was just such a fluid
process and so many ideas came up in it
and we just we just knew from there we
just needed to keep working together so
i don't know who these people are
i don't know i have nothing to ask we
didn't mean her when we've been talking
we're like the person who isn't here the
other true darcy here and i was like
what's going on but no no and we're all
horror nerds like you we love horror
that's great reaches really quickly now
what is the favorite horror movie you
can jump in on this too dan
all time yeah i'm asking you the hardest
question right now
um
i'm gonna say for me
that the original texas chainsaw
massacre is my number one
uh i i think i think the original
halloween uh is probably favorite just
in terms of like how genuinely
terrifying it was and that was i was i
was the right age kid at the time for
that to be the scariest thing that was
happening
yeah i would say for me
uh this is so hard but i guess i would
say rosemary's baby that was the movie i
think i've watched the most times and
like affected me the most and showed me
like where horror could go just to this
deeply deeply psychological place that i
loved yeah um and i would say and this
also sounds so cliche but it's the
shining i just it's so cinematically
incredible and it really takes its time
with it and everything is really
deliberate and the scare is really real
i'm just terrified of ghosts um i don't
believe in them but i'm terrified of
them and so that one really got me yeah
rock solid choices all around all right
dan now for you you obviously have had a
good deal of success
shepherding very thank you must have
been hard for you to say that
we used to date and we're very bitter
for you when you look at material like
this what is it that makes you think
this is a show that's really good and
has the potential to go the distance but
then also at this point in your career
what is something about this material
that makes you think you'll gain
something from it and add another tool
to your toolkit so to speak i'll gain
nothing from it i i um i i really liked
what these guys were saying when they
met with me about you know it's it's a
story of that focuses on different kinds
of
family relationships than we're used to
seeing focused on in in in
animation for adults uh in particular
like genre high concept like animation
for adults in this particular case like
the focus between the focus on the
mother-daughter relationship which which
you know as you guys pointed out when we
talked is like it's it hasn't really
been well plumbed in in our medium uh
and uh that was the i'm never going to
be able to do that by myself because
that would be weird for me to be
plumbing mother daughter like like
relationships with my own pen so like
like here they were ready to do that i
was like great let me help in any way i
can
and um that's that's you know and then
working with devitos like we we're
working with all the devitos
this is absolutely wild to me i love it
so much that's something you do before
you die no matter what yeah like
if you have a chance to do it even if
it's like on a gas station like if the
devitos have a gas station and then
you're like i don't want to work at the
davito's gas station
that too she's wonderful um for the
three of you just to talk a little bit
about the evolution of the story what is
the big difference what is the biggest
difference between when you first
conceived of the idea day one compared
to what we are going to see in the final
version of the show well i'd say
probably the biggest difference is that
originally it started off as a story of
a young woman who was pregnant uh and
she had a cursed womb and so obviously
things as as we kept developing the show
well we realized that she should have
she should give have already given birth
to the to the antichrist and the
antichrist just so happens to be a baby
a girl um and so
uh and then we had her at five years old
and then we realized we kept as we kept
developing the show and kept pushing it
forward
we kept aging her up too and we realized
that like 13 like is prime time
for
for any sort of like thematic like
relevance and really finding all these
different elements that we can find of
horror because 13 is such
i mean that's hell that's hell
yeah yeah no no and i think like before
this we were like working in the live
action space a lot and you know when we
started developing this idea we were
like
this needs to be animated so this was
like our first foray into it and yeah
it's been a really exciting space to
like explore and learn about yeah and
there's like with like a mother-daughter
relationship a teenage daughter and a
mother it's like like it lends itself
too well to the horror genre like yeah
so it's great
i actually
left aubry out on purpose i don't enjoy
working oh yeah oh i'm so sorry i
shouldn't have because yeah thank you
thank you for saying it danny honestly
no but we agree yeah we totally agree
she's totally the same page is a pariah
yep she's actually the best she really
is she's talking to her a couple times
and she is something else and i like how
much we're gonna talk about it how much
she is being a producing force in this
industry right now before i have to let
you all go there's so many details that
i want to touch on right now we just
don't have the time i love how much
you're pushing it with this show it's
hard to do this without giving away any
spoilers but can each of you highlight
one thing about it that made you go like
how is fx letting us do this in our
series i mean i love
that uh uh laura
as soon as the pilot gets to to rip out
a man's throat like patrick swayze and
roadhouse excellent
choice uh i would say uh i won't give
too much away but laura's entrance uh
into the metaphysical realm how how she
goes about that and that whole sequence
going into that is something okay um and
i also don't want to spoil too much but
i would say yeah that first
um the first real horror moment after
the cold open
that they allow us to go that far in
that graphic it was really
um
yeah i mean it was it opens up a huge
world what you know involving chrissy
what chrissy is capable of doing and
letting us sort of continue to show um
the graphic nature um and what she
should be doing it's just really cool
that that they allowed us to like go as
far as we did
and keep pushing that yeah it's very
effective i'm shocked at how anti-vaxxed
they've allowed us to be it's just a fun
number like like
it's it's one thing to soapbox but it's
another thing to just get your message
out there the whole second half of the
season is oh it's strictly it's never
been more important
to be anti yeah this is the time i've
never worn a mask in by 86 years all
right i'll see you later everyone
this interview's over you guys have a
real safe condition
your show is very exciting i cannot wait
to see more huge fan of the creativity
here and of course the blood gore all
the details that i've seen thus far
congratulations and thank you so much